this question was submitted by a member
of the Institute for Electrical and
Electronics Engineers part of the
magnetics community the question is can
spin be used for communication
communication long-distance
communication you mean the spin cannot
be transferred to a viral on this and
say unread the microns is a maximum that
can be first seen today so for
communication at a long distance the
necessarily is electrical current or
waves that is light or hydro waves and
so what is important is to to to develop
the possible relays for exam between
spins spin currents and emission of
light of emission of microwaves
this is very important of phila we
search today as is pooram of relay
between spins and other type of other
type of physics more Halloween for
communication at long distance